so thanks everyone for wrapping up your
conversations
great and thanks every everyone for
being here today to celebrate and bid
farewell to an extraordinary director of
nlm Dr Patty
Brennan today we've got the opportunity
to reflect on Patty's remarkable career
and countless accomplishments as she
embarks on a well-deserved retirement uh
and before turning to our first Speaker
let me uh uh refer people to the cards
in the back uh that you can sign uh if
you would for her retirement so with
that I'm going to introduce Dr Larry
tabac Dr tabac has served as acting
director of NIH since December of
2021 uh as acting director he oversees
the 27 institutes and centers and before
that uh from 2000 to 2010 of course he
was a director of the National Institute
of dental and cranial facial research
and in between he was deput principal
deputy director of NIH
Larry thanks very much Mike I I I wish
people would stop reminding me how long
I've been acting
direct but uh but I know it's powerful
of course so thank you um so I was asked
to say a very few words and to keep on
time and that's why I wrote things down
because otherwise who knows what would
happen here so I I have to say this
really is you know one of those
Bittersweet moments that we all talk
about um and and certainly at least to
me it seems like it's only yesterday
that that that Patty began as nlm
director it was August 15
2016 and in NIH time you know we talk
about dog years in NIH
years there's still a newbie I mean it's
you know so um but yeah you know here we
are um wishing her well as she prepares
to retire from government
service um we all had very high hopes
that Patty would lead nlm into the
future and my goodness she surely did
not disappoint um Patty's Visionary
approach was highly reflective of her
own background which is somewhat unique
um I say this as a dentist biochemist or
biochemist dentist um she integrates
engineering information technology and
clinical care um all into one effort to
improve improve public health and of
course to ensure the very best for for
patient care and so it was under her
leadership that LM LM grew its research
Enterprise it extended
stakeholders access to Credible and
reliable health information isn't that
nice credible and reliable information
okay um and acquired um preserved
biomedical literature using Cutting Edge
digital research and outl reach those
those efforts have really positioned nlm
as as you know the global scientific
research library with visible and
accessible Pathways to both research and
information um I'll tell you during the
last shutdown we we had the stupidity of
shutting down Pub Med and started
getting hate mail from every physician
at every hospital in the entire world
we're not going to do that
but but again it it it really just
underscored how incredibly invaluable
the the information that that is housed
here um is is is really an actionable
set of information it's a meaningful
information it's used to empower
patients caregivers clinicians and of
course
researchers and so you know as I travel
around particularly if you travel in
foreign countries when you say ni what
people really think about is nlm that's
how they they know
NIH Patty's influence however extended
well beyond
nlm um she assumed a key leadership role
in nih's overall data science efforts
and really position nlm as the epicenter
of data science at the
agency and something that we will
obviously continue to grow um going
forward in the
future now with that came the request to
review a myriad of reports coming from
multiple parts of the government places
that at least I never even heard of
before but but Patty was diligent and
reviewed every single one of them and I
will say that her insights and
recommendations were often incorporated
into those many many reports um and and
no doubt you know allowed us to get
approaches that will enhance the
practicality and the impact of things
going
forward um I'm personally going to miss
Patty's vision and Leadership on a host
of topics
um we we have we have had many
conversations about data science medical
informatics but most recently AI um I
think almost every other conversation
has been about
AI but but the most important part about
my interactions with Patty have been the
honesty and cander
um
she was honest enough and secure enough
to reach out to me regardless of what
position I was holding um and and just
tell me what she felt I needed to know
as opposed to what I wanted to hear and
as a result Patty became a very trusted
counselor uh for me
providing truly significant Insight on
into how to navigate a number of
challenges far beyond the things that
the nlm director would you know would
would worry about and so for this I'm
really really grateful so uh NIH is
going to miss you Patty and I'm G to
miss you um but we're of course very
excited and happy for you as you enter
the next chapter of your journey so best
[Applause]
wishes thanks so much much for
that and I'm going to try
to stop the slide
show there we go
and I'm not sure how I can uh let's see
here is that better than slideshow I
don't know we'll go with it so next we
have do Susan Gregor she's the NIH
associate director for data science and
director of the ni
office of data science strategy where
she leads implementation of the NIH
strategic plan for data science uh in
collaboration with uh the ic's across
NIH I should mention that Susan and
Patty have forged a strong Alliance uh
between her office and the National
Library of Medicine something that's
going to uh carry us both uh well into
the future
sues
thank you so much Mike it's really a
pleasure to be here today I did write a
few words because I was afraid that I
would just get caught up in the moment
it's such a hard day for me I'm sad and
I also feel just a little of drift that
come Monday um I'm going to realize that
my dear friend and colleague Patty
Brennan she won't be here at NIH and
that's that's going to be tough during
the past several years I've had the real
benefit and opportunity to work very
very closely with Patty on just so many
activities so let me just tell you a few
examples and I could spend the whole
afternoon talking about Patty um for
example we worked on how NIH should
share and store large data sets in the
cloud like srra um we worked on ways to
improve training in data science
including Hands-On training and I've
been really a pleasure to work with nlm
and corsera and a number of other
activities uh We've looked at
opportunities for fast Healthcare
interoperable Resources with pheno
packets that was a challenge but I'm
happy happy to say that ga4gh is
continuing that work and that was work
that we forged together um we worked on
Concepts and activities to develop use
and streamline common data elements and
access to data these things have forged
new opportunities in a working group for
common data elements and um
opportunities to improve the common data
elements repository as well as a new um
opportunity to enhance DB Gap and we're
going to continue those opportunities
and activities um in your me in your
honor Patty um we have co-chaired a
number of committees a number of working
groups and we have hosted workshops and
um seminar series for Co and and that's
really where we worked very very closely
together was in our activities with Co
so as you can see nlm and odss are
valuable and important partners for NIH
and our close relationship together with
CIT in my mind is sort of like the three
legs of data science its data
infrastructure its data platforms and
its data science
data infrastructure and data platforms
are really important when we think about
um new ways to think about data
infrastructure as we think about
infrastructure for experimental
Sciences so and working together with
our institutes centers and offices will
continue to um allow us to forge new
opportunities for the for the agency to
what um create new new programs and new
activities in data science and really to
capitalize on some of the fastmm moving
activities that are happening in the
field of data science such as artificial
intelligence Patty she's ever the mentor
teacher and head
nurse as she likes to say she gives
really generously of her time of her
energy and of her brain power um to my
benefit and to those around us at NIH
she has a real passion for research
particularly in research centered around
the patient experience and this brings
new ideas and clinical informatics and
clinical data management new innovative
ideas in Technologies such as those that
were forged with radex as well as new
ideas and artificial intelligence and
I'll tell you that I'm very very deeply
appreciative of all the time that Patty
spent with me on the 2023 through 2028
strategic plan for data science her her
thoughts her ideas her work are
Incorporated quite extensively and that
can't be replaced not only that but
she's been a co-chair and a lead on the
Amad executive committee and through her
work we've really formulated and and
moved ahead on am ahead in new and
important ways that really look at um
the community the um underserved
populations and the ethics of artificial
intelligence so that Legacy will live on
if you've ever had the opportunity to
work with Patty as I have you will
realize that she's committed um deeply
to her colleagues just as she's
committed deeply to science she's
passionate she's just an amazing person
so I think on my and I know this didn't
take too long but I think on my final
words I'll just leave you with my
favorite it's my absolute favorite quote
from Patty and it comes from one of the
over almost 200 Publications that Patty
has
written um I hope I've got your I've
read many of them they're quite good but
this is my favorite one it's from 2015
it's from um Dr Brennan and Dr B batkin
yes yep um wonderful person by the way
and and deep friend of Patty in the
Journal of Nursing sciences and it it's
really goes something like nurses
nursing does need data science but data
science needs nurses and with that petty
I'm going to miss you tremendously thank
you so
[Applause]
much thanks for that
Susan next uh is Ivor duza he's the
acting director of the NIH Center for
information technology where he provides
the NIH uh Community with secure
reliable it infr infastructure and a
variety of it as well as scientific
Computing Services supporting um the
mission critical research and
administrative activities of NIH I ever
previously served as the Chief
Information officer for the National
Library of Medicine and provided
executive leadership for all IT services
at the nlm for nearly two decades
ior
well thank you
Mike so Patty I don't know way to start
and I don't do prepared remarks so I ad
hoc all the
time so you know I've been with nlm for
many years uh dating back to ' 89 and
seen the whole you know lay of land at
nlm and what you brought to nlm was
really important Patty um you brought
the sense of one nlm the concept of team
work you know the concept of all leaders
getting together and working
together and over the six or whatever
seven years of seven years of being here
uh we see the fruits of that labor you
know that effort uh of how how
synergistically nlm is now working
together and delivering high quality
products uh and MLM was always great and
now it's really wonderful it's a great
place to be and thank you for that
um you know I remember um from the very
first uh days of uh Patty being here um
I'd be going to her begging for dollars
for for it stuff and you know and
there'd be times when she'd have solved
my problems but every time I'd visit her
she' say Ivor I think I've already given
you your your funds for the router so in
the future when I call you know that
you've already done that it'll be for
some other reason and it's for your
mentorship and all of it um I now look
at Patty you know on the ni side of
things and all the wonderful ways where
you know you've you've taken the same
concepts of teamwork and collaboration
and how you how you give off your time
as Susan well said um and how you bring
people together and you you you help us
integrate at the intersection of data
science and clinical care but also
information technology and have you
given your time to the eitc you
Enterprise it Council and and and in
your vision uh in helping us get the
digital NIH together a very strategic
effort um some of the things I look back
you know we take for granted um for many
years NIH and its information technology
have been very siloed I mean it was the
technologist trying to solve problems on
their own and what you've brought uh in
you know in collaboration with Andrea
and others is is immense it's it's
created a partnership it's created a
sense of belonging that technology
belongs to science and it belongs to the
administrative domains and so you you've
done so much for for NIH in that space
and I think people will remember you for
that um I personally you know will miss
you a lot Patty I want to say thank you
for your mentorship thank you for your
support board supporting me in this role
um I don't know I mean I words would not
be able to express my gratitude to you
and I think the organization of nlm is
grateful I think uh folks around the NIH
are very grateful for everything you've
done thank
[Applause]
you thanks
Iver
next we have video remarks from Dr uh
wiwin xan kandani he is the US National
Science foundation's assistant director
for Technology Innovation and
Partnerships at NSF he helps Advance the
US competitiveness through Investments
That accelerate the development of key
Technologies and address pressing
societal and economic
needs
good afternoon everyone my name is IR
ginani and I have the privilege and the
pleasure of leading the director for
Technology Innovation and Partnerships
at the National Science Foundation I am
honored to be able to say a few words
today about my dear colleague and friend
Patty Bren I'm also sorry I cannot be
there in person I had every intention of
joining you all up in Bethesda but
unfortunately the events of this week
have prompted me to stay back at NSF so
let me also very briefly extend my
appreciation to the organizers of
today's celebration for allowing me to
come in Via this taped message now Patty
may not recall it but she and I have
actually known each other for almost 15
years we first crossed paths in 2009
when I was a tripas fellow at the
National Science Foundation and she was
on The Faculty at the University of
Wisconsin Madison some of you may recall
ARA the American Recovery and
reinvestment act of 2009 which among
many many other things included a little
known provision on health information
technology
including an office of the national
coordinator for Health it that the
legislation established per the statute
onc was to coordinate with other
departments and agencies including NSF
to make a significant investment in
advancing the state of our health it
data interoperability Precision medicine
the whole nine
yards well that sudden investment meant
that many of us were scrambling to
determine the best way to fund advances
in health it in a way that would
meaningfully and effectively bring
together not just doctors nurses and
practitioners but also researchers from
computer science to the Social and
Behavioral Sciences to systems
engineering and Beyond to really move
the needle in this trillion dollar
Enterprise and that meant a steady Trove
of community workshops you all know how
we do this community workshops that
brought together folks from those
different backgrounds and Patty either
LED or was a helpful partner and crime
forging alliances and cultivating a
better understanding of the challenges
and opportunities for the research and
Innovation ecosystem in the space at
many of those workshops she was trying
to inform the agencies of the best path
forward and I especially as a
bright-eyed young eager AAS fellow was
trying to figure out how to take up what
she and others were saying and be able
to do something impactful with it with
my colleagues at NSF and dare I say the
Investments that resulted were all the
stronger we may not have gotten
everything right but they were all the
stronger nonetheless for her vision and
her passion and her leadership as a
matter of fact we still have a program
today joint between NSF and NIH the
smart and connected health program that
has its roots in those
workshops so it is with nothing but
excitement and enthusiasm that I learned
years later that she would be the next
nlm director in
2016 she brought a similar sense a
vision and passion and Leadership and
it's really breathtaking to hear the
impact that she has had on the
organization and on NIH more General her
focus on biomedical data science
including modern approaches to curation
and Discovery and enhancing access to
research and research infrastructure
have been
unw but my interactions with her have
also been at the inter agency level
since 2018 we have worked together to
build out new Partnerships between our
two agencies in data in AI and in the
cloud and I still recall how our teams
have met in her conference room at nlm
to really step through ways of working
together and we have both also served on
an nstc subcommittee for machine
learning and Ai and in that context her
perspectives and inputs could not have
been more valuable to NIH to NSF and to
all of the federal government she's been
a tireless advocate for the full breadth
of AI education working across the inter
agency to design an approach for
tracking our investments and their
impacts and she has championed modern
data science approaches in the inter
agency space as well enhancing access to
data and infrastructure so that anyone
anywhere can contribute to the
datadriven and increasingly AI enabled
Discovery and Innovation ecos System
she's helped agencies learn from the NIH
strides model and also helped us to
deepen the engagements and truly
leverage cloud computing to advance AI
R&D her mark on that MLA sub committee
has been
incredible so Patty as I wind up here I
want to leave you with a personal
message while I'm going to miss your
valuable leadership and perspective in
these inter agency contexts and your
efforts to bring our agencies closer
together to collaborate on a whole host
of fronts in data Ai and
Beyond I think nlm and NIH really have
huge shoes to fill on that front most of
all I am going to miss just what a
wonderful friend and person you have
have been in shaping all this work
together over the last seven or eight
years I'll miss our chats on the margins
of meetings I'll miss the incredible
wisdom and advice that you have offered
and I'll miss the personal touch that
you have brought forth but I do wish you
the very best in your retirement there
is no doubt that you have earned it and
I hope you go into it knowing just what
a profound and positive impact you've
had in your time in government and
surely throughout your career and I hope
that we will continue to keep keep in
touch thank you for everything and good
luck in your
retirement good afternoon everyone my
name
is oh well thanks thanks to Dr Jean K
Jean kandani for those remarks next I'm
going to introduce Mary woolly she's the
president of research America and align
that advocates for science Discovery and
Innovation to achieve better health for
all
Mary thank you so much it's a real honor
to be here truly is now as you uh know
those of you who know me my job is
advocacy I'm an advocate and I love
being out at NIH because it reconnects
me to what's been driving my career all
the way along so I want to first of all
just express my gratitude to NIH uh
first for the science uh which has given
me and and my family mostly healthy very
long lives I just went to my aunt's
100th birthday party I was thinking
about all the reasons for that um
secondly for giving me my career L these
many years ago a lot of years ago now um
I was my first career position was on
nhlbi funded clinical trial um which
sparked an interest that hasn't gone
away around clinical trials and I'm
going to mention the impact that I think
Patty has had um Second To None in terms
of
modernizing um ct.gov clinical
trials.gov um we knew from our work as
advocates um talking often to the
Congress and their staff that there was
demand for modern
and Patty Rose to that and I got
involved personally maybe too much Patty
I'm sorry um uh but it's because it was
deep you know a deep commitment from
long ago and and that was provided by
NIH now NIH also provided me the
opportunity to meet the legendary
Advocate Mary Lasker many years ago I
learned from her she actually convinced
me to take my job um and I I also have
been privileged to know many of the
people whose names are on the buildings
on this campus there's room for more
we're constantly working at that maybe
there'll be um a new Champion arise who
uh puts an end to these needless
shutdowns that um take way too much of
your valuable time and that of your
colleagues time that should be spent on
the Forefront of medical progress
um I pledge to you that I will continue
that I also knew Jack Whitehead whose
family donated the spectacular Louise
nevelson sculpture in front of the the
National Library building and I think
it's really moving to see that
intersection of Art and Science think
about the power of it um it was Paul
Rogers though who really got me deep
into caring about the National Library
of Medicine because he chaired the
former Congressman he chaired the um
National Library the friends of the
National Library of Medicine for a very
long time and got me engaged so you
could say that the seeds were all sewn
for me to meet and get to know and work
with Patty but it's actually not the
only place I got to know her she and I
were both members of a task force set up
by the National Academy Academy of
Medicine and the National Academy of
engineering some years ago and I
remember when I accepted that assignment
I said to for matter who appointed me I
said I don't really know how I could
possibly add value but I found out what
my value add was every time Patty said
something I said I agree with
Patty let's do that because she could
talk the talk on both sides of the
engineering and clinical community and
research community and she walked the
walk she got to the end point the
product special talent special talent so
when I learned that you were going to be
uh the new director of nlm I knew this
was my lucky day we were gonna move to
Washington we were going to spend a lot
of time together and we did we spent a
lot of time together we worked um our
teams but and also I person person you
personally worked on clinical trials.gov
it is a National Treasure it's an NIH
treasure it's a world
treasure and it's getting better and
better all the time because it's dynamic
because that that was Patty's Vision I
salute your vision my friend um Patty's
accomplished much more we've heard about
that and I imagine we're going to hear
more still with these wonderful people
who've provided remarks here you leave
an incredible Legacy for the NIH for all
of us who care deeply about the NIH and
I know there's more to come Patty but I
salute you personally as a person who I
would never describe as
retiring there's nothing retiring about
your personality you love life you love
your friends and your family and you
love this career that you have built and
given so much to so many of us in the
process so I salute you I know you will
Thrive and I look forward to hearing all
about it on that por of yours in the
Eastern Shore thank you
[Applause]
Patty thanks so much for
that so so next we have video remarks
from um Dr Christy Holmes she's the
chair of the nlm board of regions that's
our Council uh which of course it serves
as the advisory body to all of our
important policy aspects and oversees
the second step of extral Grant review
Dr Holmes is associate dean of Knowledge
Management and strategy at the and
director of the gter Health Sciences
Library and learning center at
Northwestern University fineberg School
of Medicine
hello it is my honor and privilege to
bring congratulations and well wishes to
Dr Brennan from the National Library of
Medicine Board of
Regents over the course of her service
as the Director of the National Library
of Medicine Dr Brennan has made
remarkable contributions to the National
Library of Medicine the National
Institutes of Health and the public
through the resources and services and
expertise of the nlm that support
Discovery and health now and well into
the future under her Direction Discovery
has accelerated and health Advanced
through support for datadriven research
including major infrastructure projects
such as the modernization of clinical
trials.gov and the comparative genomics
resource just to name two she's a
champion for collaboration in every
respect intern nationally across the
United States through numerous efforts
at the National Institutes of Health
including many that intersect data
standards and open science and within
nlm itself including the one nlm
initiative she is tireless in her
efforts to make sure that the work of
the nlm reaches more people in more ways
through enhanced engagement with all
communities she is an ally and has been
a champion of change to build a culture
of inclusive Excellence with within the
National Library of Medicine and Beyond
on behalf of the Board of Regents I wish
to extend our gratitude to you Patty
your read leadership of the National
Library of Medicine and your impact has
been remarkable and we are all better
for it thank
you hello it is my honor and privilege
to bring
congrat and thanks to Christie for those
remarks
next we'll have uh Glenn Campbell join
us he serves as chair of the friends of
the National Library of Medicine which
is a coalition of individuals medical
associations and societies hospitals
Health scien libraries corporations and
Foundations uh and it's dedicated to
increasing public awareness and use of
nlm services
Glen thanks Mike um and thank you I add
to what Mary said about being here at
NIH this is an incredible place and I
always take a great deal of pride in
coming here and collaborating with
people here this is a very unusual place
and your aunt reached 100 and my father
reached 101 thanks in part to research
in clinical care that is uh the Hallmark
of the
NIH um it is also an honor and a
privilege to be among the people who are
so distinguished in paying tribute to
pad
Dr Brennan and as chair of the friends
of the National Library of Medicine it's
been a privilege and a pleasure to
partner with and support Dr Brennan her
leadership team and everyone at the
National Library of Medicine over the
past 7even years in her and their
transformational work at the
library to be sure when Dr Brennan
arrived she had very big shoes to fill I
mean you're leaving big shoes to fill
but you had very big shoes to fill Dr ly
ber had transformed the field over his
35 plus years here and as Dr fouchy
noted at our recent friends Gala Patty
brought the N the library to a new level
Patty has brought unique skills and
experiences to her role as director of
the world's largest Medical Library her
approach to creating a culture of
innovation was informed and has been
informed by her work as a caring nurse
and an informatician as an engineer she
brought analytical thinking and
reasoning to how data and resources
could be structured in more userfriendly
ways Patty's development of the
Strategic plan and its implementation
have transformed the library now A
Center for data science research that
accelerates Discovery nlm's improved
products tools such as clinical
trials.gov about which you've heard more
than me speak and Medline plus and more
are facilitating better faster research
outcomes and clinical applications
thereof the library's collections now
reach more people through enhanced
engagement and wider Global
dissemination the benefits to Global
Public Health have and will continue to
be substantial and
profound seven years brings a newborn to
the Age of Reason Patty has brought
seven years of reasoning to the library
her Dynamic leadership skills ability to
analyze quickly and to reduce problems
to their most solvable elements have
enabled her to meet many a challenge and
there have been lots of
challenges given how fast she talks I
think everybody thinks she's a New
Yorker but Patty hail's from
Philadelphia home to the first public
library in the United States
another groundbreaking Philadelphian who
also wore many hats Ben Franklin said
dust thou love life then do not squander
time for that's the stuff life is made
of Patty has not squandered a minute of
her seven years at the National Library
of Medicine so from and on behalf of Dr
Barbara Redmond president of the friends
of the National Library of Medicine
Andrew B Dennis CER Jean Shipman and
everyone on our board of directors I
offer gratitude and congratulations to
Patty on a job extraordinarily done well
done along with a small token of our
appreciation a MOMA museum of modern art
design which Moma describes as irregular
and classic one which could also be used
to describe Patty's approach to change
well um irregular in another way to
Patty because that will be delivered to
your home so that we can stay regular in
our compliance with all rules and
anyway we do offer also best wishes for
you and your family and a very happy
Next Step we're not saying retirement
either because we know your journey is a
never ending one so
congratulations
[Applause]
thanks so much Glenn yes Patty does
speak quickly but she thinks even more
quickly something you learn when you
work closely with
her next we have
um oh my goodness it's my it's my time
for my
remarks yes there we go
well it is an honor to stand before you
today and reflect on the many
significant contributions that Patty has
made throughout her career and
especially at nlm and NIH you'll hear
reflected in my comments um a lot of
echos of what people have said here
already
today as you know uh from previous
comments Patty's worked alongside
individuals in the fields of engineering
nursing biomedical informatics and
Public Health for more than four decades
she has received many many honors she's
a member of the National Academy of
Medicine she's a fellow of four
professional societies including the
American medical informatics Association
of which she was President for the past
and and she is the recipient of three
honorary doctorates I almost forgot that
little fact you
know for the past seven years of course
she has been our fearless leader at nlm
she's led by example and model for us
the values of Integrity dedication and
the pursuit of Excellence she's Advanced
the goals of the nlm Strategic plan
achieving many major goals that have
taken nlm to new
heights and her tireless promotion of
diversity Equity uh inclusion and
accessibility has also taken nlm to
wider breaths uh as well in those seven
years Patty has developed a cohesive
leadership team I think ior mentioned
that and established a culture of
transparency and collaboration that will
serve us well into the future she
oversaw reorganizations at both the
level of nlm and individual divisions uh
as
well uh these include a recent major
update of Library operations to embrace
the future of impli applied information
science and service and the
implementation of a new vision of the
liser hill national Center for
biomedical Communications
she's also significantly strengthened
the nlm research portfolio with
increased investment under her uh
leadership our extral programs are
supporting the development of new
methods and training new cadres of data
scientists and informaticians shaping a
more diverse and Innovative uh future in
those fields the intramural program was
strengthened by unifying two separate
programs one on computational biology
and one on computational Health Sciences
uh under a single uh leader that leader
we're happy to have announced earlier
this month is Dr uh Richard shurman uh
he is our new scientific uh director and
at this point I'd like to thank Dr
Valerie Florence for having filled that
role for the last three years and
actually doing much of that unification
work of those two
programs Patty assured that nlm was a
leader of data science informatics and
information science not only through our
research programs but importantly also
Alo through our products and services
which form essential nodes in the global
biomedical data
ecosystem in partnership with NIH she
oversaw Innovations at mcbi including
the migration of sequence read archive
to the cloud a major multi-year
modernization of clinical trials.gov and
the launch of the comparative genomics
resource which is providing a community
engaged open science solution to
research communities across all of
NIH finally Patty has bolstered the
infrastructure of both nlm and NIH she
established an agreement with the NIH
office of research facilities that would
lead to a $30 million renovation of the
nlm building and this is the first major
investment in that building in over 70
years she also strengthened the
infrastructure of NIH by co-leading the
digital NIH initiative which rewrites
the way NIH engages and will engage in
its digital
future of course this is just a sampling
uh of what has been achieved under
Patty's leadership and all of this in
only seven years it's truly
breathtaking while Patty can uh retire
or go on to her next phase uh knowing
that her impact on the global force that
is nlm and NIH uh has been great and
that it will be very long lived and
before I uh end my remarks let me just
take on a person personal note and say
that I really appreciate all that I've
learned from Patty um I would learn
something new from her every day she uh
the assumptions that I'd have the
approaches I would take the way I
thought about things were constantly
reconsidered after talking to Patty and
in in for really a lot of good stuff
I'll also say that working with Patty is
a lot of fun I don't think a day ever
went by that I didn't meet with Patty
and have a laugh I literally laugh so
it's been fantastic Patty and for all of
the above thanks now before turning to
Dr Brennan I'd like to play a short
video that demonstrates some of the
accomplishment accomplishments of Patty
in her time at nlm hello hello hello I'm
Patty Brennan the director of the
National Library of
[Music]
Medicine I Patricia Flatley Brennan do
solemnly swear do solemnly
[Music]
swear remember first and foremost the
National Library of Medicine is about
Discovery and Discovery in two planes
one is supporting the biomedical
Sciences discoveries and secondarily to
understanding basic biomedical
informatics
[Music]
discoveries
the imprimer of trust of Our National
Library of Medicine allows our
partnering scientists to be sure that
what we deliver them is accurate is
correct and current this is a job that
only the National Library of Medicine
can do and we do it really well
[Music]
well
in addition to our electronic resources
we have a human network of 7,000 public
and academic Health Science libraries
around the country placing the nlm in
every possible County in the US this
helps build awareness of our resources
and often reaches into communities
underserved
the future is a future of data but
there's new data elements out there even
now that tell us about the health of
people sound of a baby crying or a
family having an argument the motion of
a person walking after surgery these are
all data types that we've only just
begun to explore the nih's investment in
data science will be accelerated by the
knowledge embedded in the National
Library of
Medicine
[Music]
the opportunity to direct the National
Library of Medicine building on the
great advances that Dr Lindberg and
Betsy Humphrey's provided for us was
something too great to pass on the
possibility of characterizing Health
broader than biomedic domains including
lifestyle including uh social
interactions including sense of
well-being realizing that information
alone doesn't make people's lives better
but Pathways to information research
about how to best use it and integrate
into policy and tools to make it visible
to people would make it work so I could
bring my understanding over the years of
health and the everyday experience of
people's lives into the framing of a
library that became a part of the
everyday experience of people's lives
whether they be a scientist a patient a
mom hi my name is Connor Murphy and I'm
11 years old and I'm going to be today
interviewing my mom when when my son was
11 years old story Court came to Madison
one of his questions was what do you
want to be known for now when a kid
asked the Mom what do you want to be
known for I'm thinking I'm an academic I
want to be known for what do you want to
be known for so what I want to be known
for is a career that focused on taking
what we know in biomedical informatics
and expanding the those user group The
stakeholder group to patients and
families to make these amazing tools
that we're investing in Technologies
terminologies interfaces and and make
sure that we remember the most important
person in the health care process is the
[Music]
patient hello hello
hello
gosh fortunately I got to see that first
before today because the first time I
saw it I was really pretty overwhelmed
uh I need to begin by thanking our ocpl
Jody York and our entire Communications
team for many many of the things you saw
today um we are able to reach into the
public by video and this has been really
quite important to us and so thank you
Jody and thank you to your whole team
for this um I I shared this to my family
my sister said you got to stop Chang in
your hair color so yeah thank you very
much family um usually at moments like
this people Begin by thanking the people
that have helped them come to the point
and I'll get to this in just a moment I
want to begin by acknowledging my
trainees who are here uh Lily gross and
Will Thompson are here in the first row
I run a laboratory at the National
Institute for nursing research and will
is our senior postback and Lily is our
our first year Junior postback and they
are just fabulous as we try to use
Virtual Reality to better understand
everyday Health Care problems
particularly help people self-manage uh
TR an unusual privilege of being a
director at the National Library sorry
the national dist of health is that
we're allowed to have a research program
and and it's a tease John told me this
it's a tease because you can have a
research program and you get about this
much time a week to work on it um but
we've had for five years the advanced
visualization laboratory at the uh
National Institute for nursing research
I thank the NR I thank the clinical
Center I thank ORF who built this
fantastic lab for us and um we've
launched trainees we've launched the
papers we've launched we've had great
collaboration so thank you very much um
I also want to acknowledge that we have
trainees at the National Library of
Medicine we have summer traines we have
uh postbacks post dos we have uh
sometimes people coming for short
periods of of Engagement this allows us
to extend the knowledge and the research
skills that we have at the nlm around
the world so their traines are really
critically important to what we do here
at NIH now um if you watch the the the
uh the slid show on the way and saw that
I spent a lot of time talking now I'm
one of 10 children and and talking
requires that you talk loud you talk
fast and you talk often because you
don't often get the choice um but
fundamentally the job of of a director
at the NIH is to talk and it's to more
importantly it's to learn through
listening and listening whether it's
through other colleagues listening to
the needs of our of our of our Scholars
the needs of our researchers the needs
of our public our investigators you must
be a listener and so working at the
National Institutes of Health Health in
particular the National Library of
Medicine has taught me a lot about
shutting up and listening and it's been
useful and helpful to me um the one one
of the best places I learned to listen
was with the vaggis a group of IC
directors for about five or six years
has gathered together periodically we
were brought together by Roger glass who
is now a former director of the fob
Institute he brought all the Vagabonds
the people who were in DC by themselves
we'd have these dinners and we talk and
we learn about what it was meant to be
here what do you think about this or how
do you deal with that and most important
we developed collaboration the most
important advice I got coming into the
federal government is you must pay
attention to your your staff you have to
take care of your boss but you've got to
be friends with your colleagues at your
level and so I thank you to all my IC
director colleagues who are here you've
taught me a lot you've helped me grow
you've helped me learn and you've kept
me from doing terribly stupid things in
public places which is also a terrific
help um at the National Library of
Medicine we devel we have a model of I
imposed a model of leadership let's not
for pretend it was a decision I imposed
a model of leadership that was team
based and so we started meeting together
uh in around 2016 David Litman told me
okay I'll give you six meetings and if I
don't like them I'm not coming back
those of you who know David Litman know
that that's exactly what he would have
said um but David kept coming back until
he left us later that summer to go on to
another business but we now have for
over seven years been meeting every
other week for one hour in very
efficient meetings where we talk about
resolve address and learn to listen to
each other
so that now as we Face the kind of
bizarre crisis that we're facing this
week we have the skills across our team
to know how to proceed to know how to to
to support each other's work and to
begin to advance the thinking about what
nlm should be doing during this time we
have also developed a a way of bringing
leadership through we have had many
acting individuals people who been in
acting roles during my leadership time
here and the leadership team helps
Embrace those people and brings them
forward so we have not had a skip in our
process of leading this great
institution with over 1700 women and men
who work there but we have continue to
move forward with our staff um I'm
surprised actually in in all the
wonderful remarks that were made this
afternoon that nobody mentioned coid and
you remember we actually spent three
years in a pandemic so we've had a
couple of strange things that happen but
I have to we have to point out Susan uh
Richard uh Elis Rick many nights looking
at funny diagrams figuring out where's
the data going to go how are we going to
manage this you know Susan gave a bit of
a short shift to to how intertwined our
careers have been here I probably talked
to Susan 4 to five times a day some days
and certainly never less than three or
four times a week for my entire time
here so we've been able to reshape the
organization I learned a lot about
Partnerships at the NIH when I first
came and took over the Reign from Betsy
humph who's here with us and thank you
for coming Betsy Betsy served in many
roles at the nlm for over 40 years and
her most recent role though was to be
the director director and she paved the
way she taught me to listen to people to
help understand because I came in as a
nurse and an Industrial Engineer not a
librarian and so listening to what
librarian meant but also listening to
what research means here listening to
how we engage um I'm sorry that Larry
had to leave because I'm going to tell a
story that he I'm glad I guess he
doesn't know but he should know and that
is when in my family when you when you
grow up in a big family you learned to
listen to a lot so I listen to what did
my dad do for a living my dad worked for
the Catholic missions we had 10 kids my
dad work the cathol Miss there not not
very much money in our family but my
father taught me how to express my
dreams and get other people to pay for
them so I had a terrifically successful
career as an NIH funded researcher thank
you all for your tax dollars but more
importantly when I came into nlm and I
started to look at the things that we
needed to do renovate the building
improve modernized clinical trials.gov
start the comparative geneic resource
improve the data center and IV were yes
was in my office every week you didn't
give me any money for that yet I need
more money for this I had to go to NIH
and say we need your support for this
now when you're one of 27 institutes and
you go and you say we need there's 26
other people there waiting to say the
exact same thing however what the Inter
National Library of Medicine does is it
serves science and Society through this
incredible infrastructure making data
available 24 hours a day seven days a
week even now if you wake up Sunday
morning you're going to find things on
pubn we're not going to leave you alone
and this is made possible because the
NIH has invested now NIH invests in an
Institute they look very carefully and
closely at you Susan's been watching it
from my shoulder for years every time
we've gotten funds but it's helpful
because it make sure that what we do as
a library serves the public as a whole
I'm going to take with me a whole lot of
things I'm taking with me 15 coid pounds
by the way which is a real annoyance but
I'm also going to be taking with me the
realization that this is a good part of
the government that we are able to act
as Patriots to serve science and Society
to improve the lives of individuals to
accelerate the economy through our
discoveries I'm going to take with me
the many many many Smiles I saw across
tables at dinner tables and IC director
tables and Leadership tables and zoom
screens which we saw for years I'm going
to take with me a bit of humility to
realize that no director does anything
alone in their Institute you can provide
ideas you can provide funding you can
provide support but if you don't have
that magical group of Staff with vision
and passion to do their work your work
isn't going to go anywhere so I thank my
leadership team I thank the National
Library of Med medicine staff our
trainees our investigators our all of
our Librarians we don't have that many
but we've got a couple about hundred
there we have computer scientists we
have a tremendous group that has really
brought you the information you need for
your future so thank you very much
colleagues thank you for the privilege
of
serving
[Applause]
well thank you everybody for that and
thanks everybody for coming today uh we
realize as been as has been said uh
several times today that Patty's not
really retiring she's just moving on to
the next phase of her life and her
influence here is not going to be over
uh we are going to continue uh uh moving
forward her work that she started uh
being inspired by her leadership here
for the last seven years so thanks Patty
and let me uh uh direct everybody to the
champagne and caviar we've got back
there
thanks again and thanks again for coming